Salut, je m'appelle Diana Yastramska, j'ai 21
ans et je viens d'Ukraine.
le parking
souterrain
étranger
[Musique]
il n'y a pas encore de serena donc ils sont à la
maison maintenant
ce truc la salle de bain qu'ils ont mis dans le
matelas du lit et maintenant ils sont
allongés là au cas où si la bombe arrive
ça n'ira pas  the windows
ukraine
[Music]
le 23 de la nuit
je me suis réveillé à cause des bombes
je suis allé voir mon père j'ai demandé ce qui se
passait et il a dit que
la guerre avait commencé le 24
tard dans la nuit
mon père a pris la décision que la prochaine
matin tôt
moi ma soeur et ma mère nous allons
partir en voiture
pour la
roumanie c'était genre non je ne vais pas quitter
le pays je veux rester à la maison avec
toi et ma mère je ne veux pas
partir c'était mon  première réaction
nous roulons peut-être trois heures
et c'était tellement effrayant de conduire parce
qu'on ne sait jamais  peut-être que la bosse sera
quelque part là-bas ou peut-être que tu vas
rencontrer sur la route quelqu'un ou peut-être des chars
ou
je ne sais pas c'était super effrayant
nous avons traversé euh l'ismail
et
nous sommes arrivés en voiture là
-bas et puis nous avons pris le bateau pour  aller en
roumanie
[Musique]
le bateau était peut-être sept minutes
nous devions juste traverser la
rivière c'était tellement émouvant parce que vous pouvez
voir vos parents de l'autre côté
de la rivière et
vous allez à l'endroit sûr et vos
parents restent là  je ne voulais
pas poster depuis le début
je l'ai fait juste parce que je voulais
partager et laisser cette petite histoire dans
mon instagram
[Musique]
était super triste parce que
quand on s'est dit au
revoir avec les parents le
père a dit ça  vous les filles devez partir
vous devez
suivre vos rêves vous devez
construire votre avenir
et vous devez prendre soin les unes des autres
c'est très douloureux
je ne souhaiterai jamais de ma vie que
quelqu'un ressente
comment dire au revoir à votre  famille dans
le monde
magazine
étranger
je  c'est un peu sale parce que nous nous
précipitions aujourd'hui ouais et nous aimons manger
beaucoup de bonbons
ici c'est
une pièce où nous dormons
ouais
où est le drapeau ukrainien
ivanka l'a emmenée
cette histoire avec moi déjà depuis des
années ouvert 2019
wow j'ai aussi  des jouets que ça fait
déjà des années avec moi
mais
cette fois je n'avais tout simplement pas
assez d'espace
pour eux et
tout était si rapide qu'il
n'y avait pas le temps de penser à
elle jouets tout ce que tu as mangé les chips
hier non ouais non oui
je  je ne veux pas qu'elle marche seule quelque
part et les parents nous ont dit de
toujours rester
proches les uns des autres
aujourd'hui c'est euh
lundi
prenez le métro le plus proche avec vos
documents d'eau de nourriture et vos
vêtements de ver
le matin, j'ai l'impression qu'ils sont plus
tristes et pendant la journée ça va
mieux parce que le matin ils
appellent les parents et ils parlent de la façon dont
ils se cachaient y  ous savez
pendant les frappes aériennes
qui se produisent dans la nuit, je ne peux pas
imaginer ce qu'ils ressentent
mais j'essaie de
les soulager un peu pour eux, vous
savez que
oui
dès
que vous commencez à jouer, enlevez
ça parce que ça va  sois difficile à respirer hein
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je n'ai jamais mangé ce genre de burger
c'est quelque chose de nouveau
j'aime le double cheeseburger
c'est dur d'être ici parce que
tu te sens mal mais tu dois rester
positif et tu dois
sourire et prétendre que tout est
bon c'est dur
de côté vous pouvez voir comme euh
comme j'ai l'air d'avoir l'air normal mais
pas
mieux je ne parle pas de ce qu'il y a en moi
j'ai beaucoup de pensées comme ça
pourquoi je ne suis pas là  avec la famille
dans ma ville
pourquoi je suis ici en sécurité
et les gens sont là pour survivre et se
battre pour nos vies j'ai beaucoup ces
pensées
si je ne serais pas un joueur de tennis
je resterais là dans ma ville à coup sûr
avec le  famille
aprilian day vancouver
quand j'ai quitté l'ukraine
et nous étions déjà  y en roumanie
j'ai l'impression que
la guerre se déroule avec
moi  dans notre langue
pas de guerre
tout le monde dit ça maintenant
donc
j'espère
qu'il y aura une paix dans le monde
[Musique] au
revoir
[Musique]
toi